hablemos de pasatiempos yo hago yoga
jubilee presenta reunimos a siete
personas soy blanco blanca blanco soy
blanco blanco
uno es un mentiroso con los ojos
vendados así el grupo descubre quién es
el mentiroso se repartirán un premio
está si el mentiroso sobrevive gana todo
el premio fight
el impostor temporada dos episodios 6 me
llevaron a la caja estaba muy asustada
pero tenía confianza en que iba a ganar
porque práctico os además tengo una voz
blanca está claro que no soy blanca la
gente quizá piensa que hablo como blanca
porque fui adoptada y mis padres son
blancos o bien soy anna y soy la primera
de la fila
yo soy brandon el segundo de la fila
soy ryan y soy el tercero en la fila soy
maraya y soy la cuarta en la fisio y
elisabeth y soy la quinta en la fila
soy kyle y soy la sexta de la fila soy
cod y soy el séptimo de la fila primera
ronda hablemos de pasatiempos si os
hablemos de pasatiempos yo hago yoga
no lo sé los de color también hacen yoga
yo hago yoga weiss espera eres negra no
pero creo que está haciendo muy bien
si soy yo interés cuál fue tu estrategia
para esto creo que fue simplemente
intentar ser lo más amigable posible me
estaba basando en nombres
como el auto espera espera tu apellido
es pinto como como el frijol si así
también viento es un aval caballo creo
que hay una cultura que por supuesto hay
una cultura que creo que tiene los de
color que los blancos no tenemos estoy
es en blanco
no lo sé todo lo que sé es que si
preguntas podrías encontrar algo qué
tipo de música escuchan ustedes
por eso no es cierto
me encanta justin bieber me encanta
mi estrategia era hacerlo más blanco
posible que red hot chilli peppers y las
cosas de antes esas no las apagó si
están sonando boom espera ellos son los
que cantan no es eso
yo creo que los gustos de música revelen
quién es blanco o negro mi mejor amiga
es negra y ama el country yo escucho más
que todo rap incluso rapeo un poco si me
conoces
blanco así que yo escucho la radio a
veces pero soy una persona de podcast
y yo siento que es el tipo de música que
oyes puede representar su crianza pero
no necesariamente yo creo que hay gente
de color que tiene mucho en común en
cuanto a gustos de música votos por anna
por brandon les juro que si levantan la
mano están equivocados díganme ahora fue
muy difícil tratar de averiguar quién
era solo basándonos en las voces y las
cosas que dirían por ryan por mar allá
por elisabeth por kylie no puedes votar
dos veces
kyle ese fue el nombre que sentí que no
era tan blanco en mi opinión porque no
sé por qué pero sospechaba de cody
estaba segura de que tenía razón
adios kylie adiós adiós kylie supongo
que debido a mi nombre
creo que no hable lo suficiente como
para tener un voto sólido no estaba
segura de que kylie fuera expulsada no
estaba segura de por qué la expulsaron
estaba feliz de no haber sido expulsada
no sabía los nombres de la gente pero no
importa porque si ronda dos estoy
tratando de imaginarme cómo son todos
por su voz y creo que ya tenemos a
alguien fuera que puede ser el impostor
ya no tenía ni idea de si estaba en el
mismo camino mental que yo o no crees
que cómo se llamaba
pero estoy bastante seguro que también
voté por ella cuáles son sus comidas
favoritas probablemente el sus
deliciosos california porque tienen
cangrejos y esos roles horneados sabes
microambientes no es como mejor no son
como horneados quién dijo eso para allá
[Risas]
dijo don prins esta de aquí es elizabeth
sí
pero ahora creo que esto es lo que todos
hemos estado pensando que les pareció
pantera negra no he visto esta película
todavía verguenza triste porque muchos
dijeron era bueno que lo fuéramos
sangriento fue muy popular entre la
gente de color es buena me encantó ver
pantera negra no te hace guay lanco o
negro fue una gran película muchas
personas vieron pantera negra y pues yo
también lo hice yo vi pantera negra es
por cierto me encantó fue un icono
no vi pantera negra
en realidad bueno yo sí que estoy en la
universidad apenas tengo tiempo para
leer bueno el que estoy leyendo es todos
eran mis hijos de arthur miller capítulo
en que se trata con plata de un hombre
que fue a la cárcel
y la madre cree que su hijo está vivo y
no ha terminado votos por anna
[Música]
no escuché mucho de ella así que había
un poco de misterio tal vez un poco de
su voz por brandon por ryan por mar allá
por cody
[Música]
y así me sorprendió creo que fue el
comentario de hoy de color también hacen
yoga
yo hago yoga fue en el peor momento
ronda atreví a empezar ya que estoy al
final donde estaba a na
soy brandon espera el impostor se fue
bueno lo que yo lo que yo pensaba es que
era caigo labrando la que tal bueno
un policía te detiene a morir qué harías
justo me ocurrió hace dos semanas por
velocidad fue el privilegio que puedes
oler en realidad era mi matrícula
delantera solo me dio una advertencia
realmente me molesta que cuando a
alguien lo detienen porque está haciendo
algo y no recibió una multa pero
detienen a alguien de otra raza por la
misma cosa y si le da la multa sabes si
sólo eres blanco si para ser honesta me
han seguido a casa en mi ciudad muchas
veces y lo hacen porque soy una de las
pocas personas negras en mi ciudad y ya
deberían conocerme somos pocos bajamos
godín y bien si lo dije bien
porque te suben las manos porque estoy
vendado y creo que me pone un poco
ansioso así que estás un poco ansioso
ellis en realidad ha hablado mucho por
qué
estaba sospechando de elisabeth ella no
hablo mucho
votos por brandon
por ryan por mar allá por elisabeth por
cody hay un empate brandon y elizabeth
trataba de salvarme si quieres votar por
brandon levanta la mano votos por brand
porque él era muy franco creí que no era
el impostor porque siento que si yo
tuviera que serlo trataría de mantenerme
con un perfil bajo votos por elisabeth
lo arruinaron
por favor mira me siento que mientras
menos personas es más probable que ganes
levanten la mano si desean continuar
si las luces son verdes expulsaron al
mentiroso si las luces son rojas el
mentiroso sigue en la caja y ustedes
pierden así que
[Aplausos]
o no
chica lo sabía lo sabía chicos quienes
brandon tenemos problemas sospechas de
mí desde el comienzo tú eres el short
ese es mi nombre pero me llaman li zhi
elisabeth de eso es muy blanco lo sé yo
sospeche de elisabeth por un segundo
cada vez que hablaba era algo
estereotipado de los blancos que conozco
vine a recoger mi dinero o me dios mío
es mi sueño
oh dios esto es o dios mío
gracias estar con los ojos vendados fue
más extraño de lo que pensé que sería mi
rosa es humano cuando se trata de la
raza no puedes buscar a una persona
basándote en lo que le gusta la canción
o el artista o la comida que le gusta
muchas gracias por ver el episodio de el
impostor esperamos que les haya gustado
y un recordatorio rápido diríjanse
hammam google.com para ver la nueva
colección colección 3 es nuestra
favorita sabemos que les encantará para
todos los que pidan más de 75 dólares en
ropa les enviaré un regalo gratis por
poco tiempo vean eso asegúrense de dejar
un comentario en el botón me gusta y nos
vemos la próxima adiós
jubilee vive intensamente